welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and is Marvel Studios plan for
Avengers King Dynasty completely going
back to the drawing board some
unconfirmed rumors are claiming
screenwriter Jeff loveness is being
replaced on top of the title character
in Big Bad of Marvel's Multiverse Saga
Kang the Conqueror facing some
uncertainty after Jonathan majors has
been going through some legal drama I
have held off discussing this story and
I won't be getting into all the legal
details in this video but we are going
to discuss Marvel's narrative strategy
and where they might go from here in
this Brave New World where one of their
best directors is leaving and
everybody's going on strike and if you
want to support our growing Network here
at new rock stars the best way to
support us is to grab a Multiverse dive
over at nerdriot.shop okay these rumors
about screenwriter Jeff loveness aren't
coming from scooper Jeff Snyder who
dropped this on he and John Rochas the
hot mic podcast my source is saying that
Jeff loveness is off of the Kang Dynasty
and that he fell off before the strike
there was a note even Jeff says it is
unconfirmed but this is coming out as
Ant-Man the Lost Quantum media releases
on Disney plus after making nearly 150
million dollars less globally than
2018's Ant-Man and the WASP now one of
the greatest sins in Hollywood media
coverage is singling out a movie
screenwriter for a film's box office
failure or box office success obviously
a film screenplay is incredibly
important and cannot be replicated with
AI for any Studio heads listening but a
film's performance is a factor of many
decisions and really that buck stops
with the director in the studio I think
people blame the writing or the bfx
because while directors love going on
and on and interviews about the process
and their Vision writers and VFX artists
are troll people who spin their gold in
caves or the angry Village Bob outside
doesn't understand what the job of a
screenwriter or VFX artist really
entails especially at Marvel writers and
artists are scrambling to keep up with
increasingly unrealistic demands from
above to completely rework stories up
until the last minute so if it is true
that loveness was dropped from
quantumania but Peyton Reed keeps
getting the direct Mandalorian episodes
that is total in my view but
this does speak to a bit of a perfect
storm of concerns over at Marvel Studios
for their future Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 is the biggest critical and
Commercial Success the studios had in
several titles making it even sadder for
Marvel fans that James Gunn is leaving
ahead DC for Warner Brothers many Disney
are likely regretting temporarily firing
gun in the summer of 2018 which led to
the delay of Guardians volume 3 to now
when it was originally going to start
Marvel phase 4 in May 2020. so think
about that it was gonna go in game then
far from home then Guardians volume 3.
woof now a lot of people ask me how I'm
able to stay focused researching all
these videos and honestly it's one of
these
focusing
so one shot energy juice are a healthy
and convenient energy boosting
supplement candy for gamers athletes
YouTube hosts everybody really they make
energy to choose and Focus Shoes the
focus choose are really my go-to but it
really just depends on what you need
each energy chew has 75 milligrams of
pure caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional neurotropics that give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew Focus choose now
available in limited edition new
rockstars themed packaging they really
help me concentrate and give a natural
boost of energy with BCD and E vitamins
plus zinc to help with immune system
support and the amino acid tyrosine both
the Energy Chews and focus chews are
plant-based naturally sweetened and
designed to give you the energy and
focus you need without a bunch of
fillers and chemicals get started with
one shot energy today by going to one
shotenergy.com new rockstars for 10 off
your order meanwhile the one's face of
Marvel's feature and I guess it's
present in its past Kang the Conqueror
is now a source of uncertainty on March
25th Jonathan Majors was arrested in
Manhattan and charged with several
counts of assault in the third degree
three counts of attempted assault in the
third degree one count of aggravated
harassment in the second degree and one
count of harassment in the second degree
after an incident that reportedly took
place between majors and his girlfriend
in which his girlfriend was allegedly
hospitalized now majors and his attorney
denied the accusations there has been a
lot of statements made and Majors is
scheduled to appear in court on June
13th this is an actively developing
story I am not a lawyer and the last
thing we need are YouTubers sorting
through the evidence like Nancy Grace
because you know what happens when you
do that YouTube you become pawns either
for the prosecution or the defense as
they use you to try this case out in the
media for the love of God stop doing
that I think the best thing said about
this was on May 5th by my colleague
Joanna Robinson who has co-written an
extremely well-researched book on the
MCU she's one of the top Marvel experts
with a ton of sources at the studio she
had this interesting statement on the
ringers the big picture podcast yeah I
don't think you and I are very
interested in saying like what Marvel
should or shouldn't do Etc going forward
but we know that this is a huge problem
for them that they're facing that
they're grappling with right now and
what's
unprecedented in this for Marvel is I
would argue they've never hung so much
of a franchise on one actor as they
decide to hang it on Jonathan Majors
after his Loki performance and his
Ant-Man Quantum media performance I was
told by someone who works for Marvel
that it was not the plan to make Kang
the center of everything until they saw
the dailies in quantumania and were and
after his performance in Loki which was
so strong they're like this is it this
is our way forward we've lost our
Varsity hero team but let's center
around this guy Kang in this incredible
performer that so many people are
reacting to and I would argue more than
Downey is Iron Man and like more than
Brolin is Thanos like this hanging
everything on this guy who was gonna
then crop up in all of their properties
leading up to something called the King
Dynasty has put them in a very unusual
position they don't usually hang so much
on one one person or one thing the way
that they did here and
um yeah let's put them in the bind we
don't know what they're gonna do I've
heard conflicting stories about they are
going to replace them they have they're
not even considering replacing him Etc
et cetera we don't know but it is just
one more one more thing Joanna as usual
hits the nail on the head after Loki
Marvel put all their chips on Jonathan
majors in the post-credits scene of
Batman the was Corner media they implied
that he would be playing every iteration
of Kang now yes you could argue Marvel
also bet big on Josh Brolin in the
infinity Saga and we should note that
Josh Brolin had his own history of a
2004 domestic abuse arrest that
Hollywood seems to have moved on from
but Thanos was one big name in a
universe full of heavyweights The
Avengers not Thanos were the faces of
the MCU back in those days now Marvel
seems to have lost its Varsity roster
while Kang all the kings was their
backup plan now that plan is complicated
Marvel has said they are moving forward
with Loki season 2 coming October 6th
one scene of which we saw as
guanamania's second post credit scene
with variant Victor timely there have
been some unconfirmed rumors from Alex
Perez of the cosmic circus that Marvel
is sticking with its Multiverse Saga
plan in Kang but whether or not they
stick with gang will be answered at the
end of Loki season 2. Perez also hinted
that some Kang scenes might be being
re-shot but he wouldn't say which ones
he also claimed that there was an order
on promotional material from Disney
saying that quantumania articles
shouldn't mention John the majors I was
not able to confirm any of this so take
it all with a grain of salt but if they
are reshooting anything their options
are limited the ongoing Rider strike has
already halted a number of Marvel
Productions in any new script material
being written right now for Loki season
2 would be a serious wga violation I
don't care if it's being written by that
Kevin robot they got in the ball that
robot's a scab also reports are saying
that Marvel Productions in particular
are especially at risk due to the
Studio's tendency to rewrite scripts
late into production and now the actors
Union sag-aftra authorized a strike vote
with voting closing on June 5th and if
it passes no actors will be able to show
up to set to shoot or reshoot anything
so where does Marvel go from here well
you gotta imagine Marvel Studios at
Disney are quickly drawing up
contingency plans they're not going to
talk about them but they got the plans
some might say a recast of Majors could
be done simply without Fanfare like when
they recast Brody from Terrence Howard
or Don Cheadle and Iron Man 2. look it's
me I'm here deal with it let's move on
or who knows Marvel could give several
actors a huge opportunity and cast a
dynasty of seven up and coming actors to
play the whole Kang Dynasty but really
it is too soon to speculate majors has
not been convicted of anything and in
this country you are innocent until
proven guilty we gotta let this play out
you could say Marvel should wait until
Majors next court appearance on June
13th but that strike vote ends on June
5th and this case is going to play out
for months so that studio is likely
moving fast on backup plans behind the
scenes I am going to propose something
extreme it suggests that no matter what
the news brings over the next several
months this July at Comic-Con Marvel
Studios would definitely benefit from
announcing a hard reset after phase six
with Avengers Secret Wars just
acknowledge that things are crazy and
directionless right now in the
Multiverse Saga Embrace that chaos as
part of the plan and say that after all
these forces Collide in secret Wars the
franchise will we promise do a hard
reboot with a new lineup of Avengers
Fantastic Four X-Men and the rest a new
Tony Stark new Wolverine new t'challa
some actors might survive Secret Wars
and remain some will return to their
home universes some might die forever
but after the dust settles leading a new
616 will be a lineup of Marvel heroes we
can really get behind that way we'll all
be going into Secret Wars campaigning
and pulling for our particular hero to
survive the reset it'll be civil war
Infinity War all over again let them
fight it out it'll give the world time
to sort itself out but I want to hear
from you what course do you think Marvel
should take hey reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and get
support us by grabbing some merch like
our Multiverse dive shirt and
nerdright.shop also subscribe to our
third channel the break room you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow me rockstars And subscribe
to norikstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you